thanksgiving evening is the greatest
time ever if you're young to be single
you go back to your hometown you go to
the bar those all of those chicks you
went to high school with they're all
thinking of the guys they should have
banged you're thinking hey that's one of
the great [ __ ] hookup nights there
was way better than christmas eve you
wake up hungover you feel like [ __ ] you
were out late oh you're young you're
young you feel great you're you're
grasping for straws paul you're single
you got no [ __ ] kids you're going
back and you finally got you got the
courage you got your swag now you can
walk up to that woman you were afraid to
walk up to when you were in [ __ ] high
school
and maybe something the excitement of
that paul the hope
waiting for santa claus how about
waiting for that [ __ ] chick you've
been thinking about for the last seven
years to come walking in the bar that's
excitement hey